[Applause]
another celebrity revealed on the masked
singer
fellow comedians and the show's
panelists Joel McHale and Ken Jeong
couldn't even figure it out and I
thought you would know I know she's my
sister on dr. kay a pioneer in
asian-american comedy she the reason
Margaret is the fourth singing celeb to
get the boot although we'll have to keep
watching to find out who the rest of the
secret singing stars are last week the
identity of yet another one was revealed
when the deer was unmasked had the
choice at the beginning just they said
do you want to know and I felt like as
the host that would take away you know I
wanted to find out when the audience
found now and you see the surprise on my
face he caught up with panelist Robin
Thicke ahead of Wednesday's episode
where he dished on the reveal I think
that's exciting about the show is when
they do a different song you get
different ideas about who it might be
just by the choice of song or by the
vocal tone in that song so if somebody
you thought you were sure of last week
you might completely change your mind
this
you
[Music]